l' aventure de montigny-le-bretonneux en
coupe de france régionale s'arrête au
stade des 32e de finale les signé mon
teint qui évolue en division leur se
sont inclinés contre roissy l'équipe de
prénationale deux divisions de sucre de
la snb après un premier quart d'heure
convaincant au les vert et noir ont fait
jeu égal avec leurs homologues dont il
n'y a craqué dans les dix dernières
minutes de la première période il n'a
jamais pu combler ce retard de cul suite
score final 33 à 25
en effet on a perdu mais je suis assez
satisfait de l'équipe parce que nos
réussi à tenir une équipe qui évolue en
prénationale pendant 15 minutes qu'on a
fait jeu égal pendant 15 minutes après
ça s'est joué sur des détails techniques
essentiellement la finition pour
commencer on a eu pas mal d'échecs au
shoot une défense un petit peu un petit
peu trop laxiste si on a en a beaucoup
trop attendu à 6 mètres et ça nous a
coûté cher
malgré cette défaite
montigny-le-bretonneux aura réussi un
parcours historique dans la compétition
les joueurs ont réussi à éliminer deux
équipes de prénationale pour se hisser
en 32e de finale
une première pour le club on est allé en
normandie cette année c'est la première
fois qu'on sort de la région parisienne
c'est sympa ça fait toujours plaisir
après oui c'est la première fois qu'on
arrive aussi loin j'espère qu'on fera la
même chose dans les prochains mois au
moins aussi bien prochain objectif pour
monty lions retenus se reconcentrer sur
le championnat de division honneur pour
espérer monter cette année les i
montants sont actuellement la première
place du classement avec seulement deux
défaites depuis le début de la saison
[Applaudissements]